[Music]
ghost in the shell' shatters the logo
record with an hour and 15 min I mean
one minute and 15 seconds of logos when
I saw Rupert Sanders was a part of this
film I was surprised since by taking
this job there was no way of cheating on
his wife with Kristen Stewart Linda
should just go ahead and give a paper I
wrote in college we're all doomed
computers are going to cut our asses a
writing credit maybe it will also
receive an F for my human replacements
professor for being a remake of another
paper somebody wrote 22 years prior I
understand that we have to see what's
going on but why would they have this
random window that looks into the
contents of the life water if it's like
a sea otters in the zoo exhibit
shouldn't there be more people here to
see it whitewashing hey she still shows
the scenes on her face but she's got
fully formed and trimmed fingernails
apparently the synthetic body doesn't
need to look realistic because this
movie is aiming for a pg-13 rating to
officially become a sentient human you
must ingest a massive dose of LSD and
she can't be can only follow orders but
as a human mind in a cybernetic frame
here I can do all those things and more
something that's never been explored
before in movies like The Terminator The
Matrix trilogy or ex machina or AI a
Robocop or Tila and the future of my
company evil rich corporate asshole once
the turn sideway we're into a weapon so
you can get even richer and evil or
cliche movie imagines a future where
holograms littered the city landscape
with advertisements unfairly certain
Holograms are not the fucking future but
man movies ever think they are anyway I
feel free to laugh at us from the Year
2286 also the scenery in this movie is
amazing I'll give it that but the only
advertisements in this city are four
cybernetic enhancements engine I mean
doesn't anyone need to be reminded to
drink a coke anymore
considering the hyper reliance on
visuals I'm starting to think this movie
could have been dialogue free and made
the exact same amount of money there's
an echo box up here someone's scanning
data traffic solution will do cellophane
it's worthless conserving don't you know
isn't that why you're here what brought
you to the hotel in the first place if
you're just now realizing there's an
echo box and you don't know who it is
being surveilled accessing hotel
security network why would the security
network give her this type of you it
would either be security cameras or a
bunch of pass codes and stuff now look
into the matrix Shannon died Julianne
dumbing hai jalwa your ex has days
remember on
damn dude couldn't you just started with
that instead of having major scan the
entire hotel the Zune technology has
gotten pretty amazing in the future but
the enhance has a ways to go
gentlemen excuse me I think there's a
highly sensitive meeting going on
between dr. Osmond and the president of
the African Federation and they left to
rent-a-cops outside to take care of
anyone who steps off the elevator and it
appears there were almost zero other
security measures taken for this meeting
to me design major discount Tropic
Thunder Jack Black yeah
uncle robust up this window this cyborg
feels the need to announce its presence
before hacking into this guy majors hair
was flying freely so it wasn't a part of
the camouflage armor but why does it
camouflage with the rest of the suit
major started her death falls over 30
movie seconds ago and the building's not
that tall but I guess she hovers outside
until after the thugs come in shoot up
the place get the orders and suck Guy of
gisbourne's brain out before she opens
fire on these assholes god damn it how
did she create enough force to break
into the window even if she was falling
straight down is this iron man suit if
you were going to remake this why not
use the beginning from the original
movie which was much better leather and
when Hank over brawn can be destroyed so
no further questions then major your
engine that's right if you voluntarily
leap off a skyscraper to do a physics
defying window entry you can escape with
only a convenient flesh wound
majors addictive reinforcements well
there's so many goddamn 3d hologram fish
around here this is an advertisement for
fish to fish even need advertising and
what do we have on Osmond he was ahead
of hand Kosovo expedition and to
demonstrate his status I will only show
you his head following last night's
attack three more hunger scientists were
murdered even though we saw the
president of Hanko get attacked and the
Geisha BOTS said collaborate with hanka
robotics and be destroyed we didn't feel
the need to warn anybody from the
company that their lives might be in
danger all showed signs of cerebral
hacking even though everyone walks right
through these Holograms togas ah can
literally grab one and pull his fuckin
collar down
hey you know GU those early dude oh no I
had two or more would have done did
anyone survive that attack and even if
they did the attackers had plenty of
time to kill all those fools before
major showed up I will find him and I
will kill him it's what I am built for
isn't it my programmer Liam Neeson said
so
you know this is what the original ghost
in the shell was missing more shots of
bateau feeding stray dogs instead of
hunting the criminal they just vowed to
kill you have damage in general systems
maybe next time you can design me better
also maybe next time you could design me
a little more culturally appropriate see
everything all of you have stopped your
petition
I guess privacy is just for human god
damn it this movie's dialog is worse
than a freshman philosophy term written
after for gravity bong hits well while
you guys conduct this super fucking
dangerous experimental data finding
mission I'll be over here in flavor
country ghosts in the cell that's all
you needed to do just pull the plug
did this movie even watch the first
movie also after we found out the data
that ran through this geisha bot was
deleted as soon as it transmitted and
after the bad guy took pains to lay a
trap inside its memory major thinks
koozies location is going to be that
easy it's like this movie put Blade
Runner The Fifth Element and attack of
the clones and a blender added pop rocks
and diet coke smashed it with a baseball
bat then fit you know for a story that's
supposedly set in Japan there's very
little Japan happening there's a lot of
heat in here for a nightclub it's Yakuza
club what did you expect
Bato would be amazing at cinemasins I
hope this guy didn't pay PPV prices for
this fight it looks like pit fighter if
you ran it on the analytical engine this
guy laughs at major from punching
distance also this entire action scene
cutting not only the action of cutting
between two different locations bull
fighting also I know major is fast and
all but this dude can't shoot her this
distance he deserves to spend his
remaining years as a stormtrooper
commander synaptic scanned you
everything you witness went to section 9
yeah but the only human part of majors
are brain right so why can't everyone be
synaptically scanned to ensure the
accuracy of eyewitness data fairly it's
perfectly okay to walk into a surgery
room where tissue would bone and muscle
are being rebuilt even without
protective equipment you are not
authorized to deep dive acacia
oh yes I was I paid the hundred bucks
you know what everyone will become one
day you don't know how long that makes
me feel
seriously the original animated version
of this movie with through several
minutes long stretches with no dialogue
and random city shots but it was much
less boring than watching this thing's
long is section 9 missing some critical
operational resource still no one else
visit it shouldn't go too
English in Japanese out and vice-versa
shouldn't cutter speak Japanese if you
can understand it or are both men being
assholes by speaking different languages
to each other human that's racist I can
see her face
boy we really abandoned though we gotta
find kuzey immediately train for this
part of the movie it feels different
such poetry by the way I can't wait
until this movie gets a prostitute to
describe the color red later the actress
asked the director what's my character's
motivation and he replied to smoke as
many cigarettes as possible most
everyone who worked on a project called
to five seconds why didn't kuzey kill
all the scientists on the same night he
went through the trouble of killing for
scientists in one night decided the
others could be saved for later is
anyone else under this me man the
goddamn thing isn't finished showing all
the people yet but yes of course there
is it's the one character we care about
so kousei is basically God I guess if he
can control the minds of two trash truck
guys and have them accelerate to the
exact moment doctor relay drives by then
I don't know how he hasn't won yet why
is he walking out into the water this
accomplishes nothing except for a cool
fight location we have movie this is it
contains exact scenes from the original
but the story is different the change in
the story really affects this scene in
particular since they don't even bother
to develop this guy's character movie
leaves out the part where major actually
tracks this asshole figures out a way to
get in front of him has time to get her
suit working and has the foresight to
put on the camouflage underwear this
morning just in case she'd get into a
fight with a trash man she hardly ever
wears that this movie also why does she
even need the camouflage she's shown to
be capable against people with guns so
this is just a waste of camouflaging
power anyway the scene now that I've
kicked your ass a little bit I will now
reveal myself for no reason but she's
standing right there they're barely able
to hear the dude so why couldn't major
conduct the interview on the outside of
the cell goddamn is movie is way more
interested in showing off unnecessary
tech than it is actually telling a story
missions fantasy reality brings memories
ghost in the shell' remake briefly
becomes a remake of the Total Recall
remake this cuba's cure it can't be
major lie detector he must have hacked
in that way are you telling me the lie
detector is connected to the Internet in
this world why would you ever have a lie
detector go over a network don't go
under no no no she does
nobody on the team follows up on the
whole don't go inside a secure cell with
the incredibly dangerous hacker avatar
threat also can't you just hologram in
there again god these assholes continue
to think things will be that easy just
like everything that's happened in this
movie yeah I was done with that guy
anyway also such a 9 breaks the first
rule of holding prisoners don't put a
noose around a prisoner when you're
interrogating him and when we couldn't
find even zoom in - to create a net
market economy cool but tell me why did
he decide in this instance to use a
cocaine debt also the sense does this
make even if he's using human minds and
network with each other we eventually
have to network into the actual network
considering koozai is able to access
random like the lie detector back at the
interrogation room strange streaky
strobe struggles strenuously strives to
be stressful tell me who you are what
are you doing to me what do you want
from me what are you talking about I
don't know about you but I think we've
got scar Jose Oscar sizzle reel right
here eat your heart out Merrill and they
came NASA nated with you reading your
code while you were inside that issue it
made everything in my plan become clear
in addition to giving me gigabytes of
strong material you were born of lessons
from my failure man when you think about
the motivations of the villain here and
how they mirror the search for majors
true self you really start to meditate
on the meaning of conquer one do you are
this is the third time this movie has
pointed out the obvious that Scarlett
Johansson is really really pretty late
on that we would be a part of their
evolution but they have created us to
involve alone and a militia that's what
you can killing everyone who meet you
what did you say say anything close to
what would inspire that question more
will die until they tell me what they
took considering that you have almost
unlimited access to everything I don't
know why you don't know this yet is not
a cheap excuse for some bonding between
to synthetic characters in the shape of
a cheap tattoo I'd say on a kitchen to
remember when I am haunted by it
I'm guessing Michael Pitt described his
accent in this movie as Seibert major is
swimming in the scene much like she does
in the original only the original brings
up how
dangerous it is for cybernetic humans to
go deep in the water like this because
you know they're made of heavy machinery
but this movie doesn't mention it once
since the scenes compressed so much it
feels like it's in gift format
I guess major uses the same longitude
and latitude when she goes diving
because you're Andre joy is in the
exactly she surfaces this is an
important scene I think I don't know
anyway all I can focus on is the
hologram in the background that is
constantly running in place but product
is being sold here if it's anything
except a treadmill I will be
disappointed I need you to take me back
there's more I need to find out why does
major need Bato to take her back she
made it all the way out here on her own
and she didn't even know he was coming
also not that I mind but why is major
stripping off the wetsuit here she
definitely didn't bring any dry clothes
with her when she came up from the water
I want to be told her this is a
futuristic phone call
damn you'd think that with all the
technology they could make it sound
better than skyping over ISDN she's no
longer a viable asset you should be the
one to do it
movie skills that you should be the one
to do it moment from iRobot the guards
who know damn well what kind of threat
major is don't bother with any kind of
weapons because they can take her down
with their puny human arms the guards
much like a John wick movie appear out
of nowhere one by one so that major can
fight them with maximum coolness what
were the circumstances by which this
dude was able to catch up on foot to
major on a motorcycle feels like when
shooting this scene they started with
the motorcycle in park accelerated to
five miles an hour and told the do to
start running after it now it'll look
great when we edit it I'll take that
under advisement
is there some sort of hologram
compatibility in this office I have all
the same questions I did when I watch
the Resident Evil extinction how does
she go from room 1804 to room 1912 on
the same floor and almost next door to
each other
fasten one so close the room this woman
doesn't recognize her own daughter which
means Hank a changed majors appearance
to look more American which is what evil
corporations do when they want to make
more money when they make movies I mean
cybernetic units my daughter died a year
ago
toko is Japanese mom is speaking English
here even though we're in Japan and
major clearly understands Japanese
considering that's the only language her
boss speaks
wrong kill gone then occasional Kimba
since you aren't already on mine comms I
don't know how you'll get this message
but our Maki can shoot and kill two
guards with all this protective gear
barely looking while holding a briefcase
in front of it but the two guards who
have all the advantages can't even hit
him in the legs that's right walk up
slowly to the guy you've been ordered to
kill you don't need to tape an open shot
or anything damn it smooth
turning into every generic action movie
ever there's a convenient mirror in this
restaurant just in case people are
stealing salt and pepper shakers the
owner wants to keep tabs on that it may
be well into the future but I see
product placement hasn't changed a bit
because this place is this where Hank
and employees take their smoke breaks
[Music]
and that is one efficiently expositional
memory that kind of ends before anything
happens
hmm now oh that's you nan
you gotta love how this movie explains
how these characters are white like it's
not something the movie itself
engineered it's the evil fictional
corporation guys not us don't blame the
studio that would just be silly also how
does he know he was a day all she did
was look at these etchings in the wall
and suddenly she knows what his real
name is I was thinking maybe it's
because of this they said you passed you
ripped all dr. hooli Gaber was a key to
her old apartment so she could track
down her mom she didn't give her like
downloadable memories or anything and
how does he know her real name don't
they look different than they did before
this happened cut her mom's tooth out of
this place then when it comes to
actually killing major and coos a he
takes control of the spider tank which
shoots bullets poorly probably because
of his reliance on this hologram sure
shoot regular ass bullets at an armored
tank what could go wrong nature pulls
some major bull Legolas here running up
these falling slabs like physics no
longer exists oh I know I'll use
something better than bullets this time
but pretty much no reason at all cutter
waits to kill coos a because apparently
he knows he's in the movie he needs to
milk the drama even though these bullets
have zero chance of destroying the tank
at all and cutter is controlling this
thing remotely he decides to go after
major right now instead of just killing
coos a now and then going after her
just a client where was this missile 90
seconds ago target and then the negative
and I base that on absolutely nothing he
came close you freak or stalling
bullshit when they named this dude
cutter definitely didn't reflect his
time management problem with this is
this movie has never shown major to have
incredible strength in the 1995 movie
there were reminders everywhere how
lethal she was this movie not one scene
informs us of this kind of strength it
comes out of nowhere also man that has
to be the most pg-13 ia's way to rip an
arm off I've ever seen come man
there's place for us here your proposal
would require a scene from the 1995
original that is way too weird for
American audiences to take talking us
into you
what are you waiting for do it okay this
is where the villain became a true
villain in my mind he's yelling at other
people because their way need to kill
the target but when he dicks around
twice with the same target that's
totally okay in his book thank you so
much
sorryto x mark it up Tom this is just
what I was built for so to do all dole
you my name is major and I give my
consent
if this consent protocol actually meant
anything at all this might have been
pretty badass but it never did it just
feels like pandering to the five people
who like this because I'm kind of your
actual daughter but not really and I'm
totally not pretending to be with my
haircut and subtle makeup choices my
mind is human motherfucker you're going
to wait till the very end of this movie
to add some bulk narration Jesus this
movie was dumped down we cling to
memories as if they define us but what
we do to find us thanks Batman
Tom all of majors operations apparently
require the backwards falling off of a
building to get the job done
whoop-dee-doo what does it all mean
Vasil swan boat their refugee
[Music]
I will find him and I will kill him
good luck you killing some people
innocence is that that what you call
them only in a world ish D could you
even try to say these were innocent
people and keep a straight face
tis but a scratch a scratch the arms off
there it isn't the love that then other
worse
[Music]
my spoon cousin Victor is dull you twit
in hot nor lady's whiskey since 1945
I bet this is a child of Prayer pathetic
you lie until you who am I
for you